foreign
do you know that one of the important
reasons most organizations are not able
to be fully data driven is that a major
portion of data generated today is
unstructured
data in the form of videos images
documents remain untapped by
organizations and one of the goals for
Google cloud is to help organizations
realize value from data of all formats
and types
Advocate Google and today I'll
demonstrate how we can store and process
image data with bigquery late last year
we announced a preview of this
capability that is to be able to store
unstructured data in bigquery and
perform analytics and ml directly on
this data using bqml with existing
Frameworks like SQL and remote functions
in this session today we'll see a quick
demo of this feature
so what's unique about processing on
structured data with bigquery you ask
you can store unstructured data in
object tables just like you would with
regular tabular data perform analytics
and ML on this data only using SQL
queries unify structured and
unstructured data at scale and query
them together
[Music]
foreign
there are five steps in achieving image
data classification with bigquery ML
create data set and weekly connection
create a cloud storage bucket and Grant
permissions create an object table
create model and upload to Google Cloud
Storage load the model into vqml and
start inferring
let's start the demo
log into Google Cloud console and in the
search bar type in bigquery if you
haven't already enabled the API you'll
be prompted to do so once that is done
you should be able to see the Explorer
pane on the left side and the query
editor on the right in the bigquery
console
the first step is to create data set for
that start typing in the query create
schema project ID dot dataset name in
this case I've chosen yoga underscore
set underscore IO as a data set name
for this demo I've already created this
once this is created you should be able
to navigate to the created data set and
take a look at the configuration moving
on to the next step
create connection this is the big lay
connection we'll be creating for this
click on the add icon on top of the
Explorer pane
from the list of popular sources select
connections to external data sources
select connection type as big lake and
remote functions Cloud resource
provide a connection ID
make sure the region that you choose
here in location type is same as the one
that you've created for bigquery data
set
and create connection once the
connection is created you should be able
to see that from the list available here
make a note of the service account ID
for the bigly connection that is just
created
next step is to create Google Cloud
Storage bucket upload the images and
Grant permissions
for this go to Google Cloud console and
on the search bar type Google Cloud
Storage or cloud storage once you select
that you should be able to see the
buckets page with the list of already
created buckets if you have any you can
choose to create a new bucket for this
use case provide the name of the bucket
and select the region make sure it is
the same region that you have chosen for
the bigquery data set and the big lay
connection
we leave the rest of the options set to
default values for now and hit create
I've already created the bucket that's
required for the demo and I've uploaded
the images for this demo we have chosen
the use case of recognizing yoga poses
so I have taken a few yoga poses images
that are available publicly and I've
uploaded those folders into the yoga
underscore images bucket that I had
created in Google Cloud Storage once you
create the bucket uploading the files
into the bucket is very straightforward
you see the upload files and upload
folder options right here on the yoga
images bucket
click that and upload the files into
this bucket once everything is done go
to the configuration page of cloud
storage bucket that you've just created
and make sure you copy the GS util URI
because this is the URL that you'll be
using in our SQL to reference this
Google Cloud Storage bucket and now
let's Grant permissions to the service
account so bigquery can access the
images stored in cloud storage bucket
for this I'm going to copy these two
commands and run it in Cloud shell
terminal
replace the service account placeholder
and
the gsutl URI of the cloud storage
Bucket Place holder
let's run the two commands from cloud
chill terminal
authorize
and we should be all set to move on to
the next step which is creating an
external object table the external
object table is the table in bigquery
that will contain the images that we
currently have stored in cloud storage
bucket for this we will use the create
or replace external table query create
or replace external table datasetid dot
table name of your choice in this case
I've chosen yoga underscore poses
underscore ieo with connection
connection name for the big lay
connection we just created options
object metadata remains simple and Uris
paste the gsutl URL of the cloud storage
bucket that we created
I've already ran this query the table is
created once the table is created you
will be able to navigate to the table
and look at the schema
now that the table is created let's
quickly query this table
the data field contains the reference to
the image
and you can see other fields URI content
type updated and other metadata fields
you can also notice that I've limited
the recent set to 1 and I've chosen an
image from the blank folder
now let's quickly visualize the results
that we obtained in an image format
to do that you can export this result
into a local CSV file
open the collab notebook
upload the CSV that we have just
exported from the query editor in
bigquery and run the small snippet this
step is totally optional and there are
several ways to do it you can also
programmatically achieve this using your
favorite programming language now that
we've created the external table and
stored images in bigquery the next step
is to create the model and upload it in
Google Cloud Storage for this
implementation I'm going to use an
existing pre-trained model you can use a
pre-trained model or create your own
model and upload it in tensorflow hub
and it should unpackage into saved
underscoremodel.pb under variables
folder in your local
upload the saved underscore model.pb
file and the variables folder into the
same bucket in cloud storage where we
have already stored our images
that's it now we can load that model
into bigquery ML and start predicting
for this we are going to use the create
model query create model dataset name
dot model name of your choice in this
case it's resnet underscore IO options
model type remains tensorflow and model
path is your GS util URI path of the
clock storage bucket that we've created
run this in this case I've already
created the model once the model is
created you should be able to navigate
to the model and take a look at the
configuration details
click schema tab and you should be able
to see two sections labels and features
labels section contains activation
underscore 49 fields it contains a batch
of vectors that represents the
likelihood that a specific image belongs
to a particular category
input underscore one is the independent
variable or the input that we will be
passing to the prediction query in order
to deliver the target result
all right now it's time to use the model
that we've created to start predicting
for this we are going to use the
ml.predict SQL select star from ml dot
predict provide the model name in the
parameter
and a sub query that represents the
image for which you want to do the
prediction
in this case the yoga post that you want
to label
let's run the query
when the query execution is complete you
can see that the result set has
activation underscore 49 which is the
prediction variable result and input
underscore one
this result is highly nested so I've
written a simple flattened query to
translate this into a more relatable
format or structure that we I'll have to
label in the form of an index or in the
form of actual yoga post name
let's run this query
there you go we have now obtained a
flattened version of the same result we
got in the prediction query in this case
the image 1.jpg that I've passed in as
input for prediction is identified as
downward dog to validate this go ahead
and Export the result to a local CSV
file and go back to the same collab
notebook where you have the python
snippet and pass in the CSV that you
have just exported and you can see that
the post that we have passed in for
prediction is actually downward dog pose
now that we've created the model loaded
the model in bigquery ml and predicted
using the model that we've just created
the last step here is my favorite part
which is unifying structured and
unstructured data and querying them
together in order to do this I have
already created yoga underscore health
structure table in preparation for this
demo
this is a simple structured relational
table which has four Fields so I'm just
going to execute this select query that
combines unstructured data and
structured data
and run it from bigquery editor
and there it is we have successfully
unified structured and unstructured data
as you can see post health benefit
breadth Focus are all from the
relational table and their field is from
the unstructured external table in
bigquery
[Music]
congratulations we have successfully
stoned queried and classified
unstructured data with bigquery only
using SQL and also unified structured
and unstructured data in a single query
as if they coexisted
try out SQL only ml with bigquery to
begin with and come up with innovative
solutions for your organization become a
Google Cloud innovator and Innovative
Champion today read about it in the
description
[Music]